la simple idée d'aller faire les courses
dans les grands magasins pour les
cadeaux de noël vous donne un
haut-le-coeur rabattez-vous sur internet
de plus en plus de français choisissent
cette solution et les ventes devraient
encore augmenter de 50% par rapport à
l'année dernière
la toile est devenue un magasin à part
entière et s'ils le font beaucoup
d'efforts pour que les clients soient
livrés à l'heure le père noël ne peut
pas être en retard séverine lebrun
fallait rica pour chaque jour ils
parcourent des kilomètres
son rôle préparer les commandes d'un
site de vente en ligne
c'est comme le pen l'ouest l'enlève
common essaie de satisfaire le client
fait des sauts que le produit puisse
arriver à temps ici on s'active depuis
quatre mois pour le grand rush de noël
van % du chiffre d'affaires de l'année
la charge dans la voiture
rapidement l'objectif que tous les
cadeaux arrivent à temps sous le sapin
gérer l'expédition en quelques jours de
milliers de colis c'est le principal
problème des vendeurs sur internet
il faut éviter les embouteillages pour
les plantes de noël on attend jusqu'à
trente mille colis par jour et on a
multiplié le personnel par trois c'est à
dire environ 250 personnes qui sont
dédiés à l'activité de préparation de
colis et d'expédition car l'année
dernière dix millions de français ont
acheté leurs cadeaux sur internet et
près de 40% ne les ont pas tous reçus
dont les délais prévus
c'est le cas de cet internaute il
pensait faire des économies en achetant
un téléphone sur le web
au final le téléphone n'était pas sous
le sapin et noël a coûté cher
et quand on fait la somme du cadeau
initial plus de le cadeau de ses
institutions et en arrivent à des frais
dits sont totalement différent de ce que
l'on pouvait s'attendre initialement
alors pour rassurer les clients certains
sites internet développe les points
retraits ici on peut venir chercher son
colis commandés en ligne et parlé à un
interlocuteur en chair et en os ce qui
les rassure un environnement physique un
endroit pour venir se plaindre en cas
problème ramener le produit s'est pas
virtuel on va dire on peut toucher du
doigt cette année les cybermarchands
comptent augmenter leurs ventes de 50% à
noël alors un conseil pour les
internautes ne pas attendre la dernière
minute pour passer commande
c'est